It's easy to say that "superheroes don't kill"
and believe it, since comic book publishers
usually prefer the good guys to find better
solutions than murder.
But as writers and trends passed, some of
the comic world's most iconic superheroes
have delivered some insane kills.
Whether they turn your stomach, or give you
a cold chill, even the brightest heroes have
their dark side.
Here are 5 Superheroes With Shockingly Deadly
Dark Sides.
Wolverine
On the comic book page, live-action movies,
or even cartoon TV shows, Wolverine has proven
to be one of the most ruthless and efficient
killers in the Marvel Universe.
Honestly, it would be hard to even know how
many lives Logan has ended with his razor
sharp claws alone.
But not every kill Wolverine makes is a righteous
one.
In "Ultimate X-Men #41," a young boy learns
that developing a mutant power isn't always
a dream come true.
Instead of a superpower, he gets a curse,
causing every person, family member, friend,
and even dog around him to burst into flames,
and burn to ash.
It isn't long until Wolverine tracks him down.
Cracking a beer, Logan tells him there's no
cure his mutation, and even worse, nobody
can ever find out that a mutant could kill
over 200 people by accident, or they wouldn't
even trust the X-Men.
Since the boy can't go on living, there's
only one thing to do.
Readers only get to see Wolverine exit the
cave, but it's obvious he put the innocent
boy down before he could kill again.
It might be the so-called hero's most haunting
kill, and more than any other, raises questions
about what being a hero really means when
lives are on the line.
Green Lantern
DC's space cop may have disappointed at the
box office, but in the comics, his story is
even stranger.
During the ultra-gritty and violent era of
1990s comics, DC decided that the best way
to get Green Lantern back in the headlines
was to do something shocking, just like the
Death of Superman had sparked new interest
in the Man of Steel.
The answer was to go the opposite route: where
Superman died, Green Lantern would become
a mass murderer.
Really.
After his entire city was wiped off the face
of the Earth, Hal Jordan didn't take long
to let his anger loose on the Green Lantern
Corps, setting his sights on the Guardians,
his all-powerful bosses.
Hal sliced through dozens, hundreds, thousands
of other Lanterns on his way to Oa, killing
all but one Guardian.
Taking the new name Parallax and some shiny
new armor, Hal was as crazy a villain as you
could imagine.
Luckily, he died before he could succeed in
destroying the universe, and DC later explained
his madness away as an infection from a galactic
fear parasite.
But whatever the reason, Hal Jordan became
one of DC's most prolific serial killers in
a matter of hours.
Spider-Man
It seems like even the funniest superheroes
get their darker stories, and for Spider-Man,
it came in the form of "Reign," a limited
miniseries taking plenty of influences from
Frank Miller's "Dark Knight Returns."
Set in an alternate future when Peter Parker
is close to 70, and long retired from the
job, the former webslinger returns to the
streets when crime gets out of hand.
But it's the death of Mary Jane Watson that
keeps him up at night.
It's bad enough that Peter leaves Mary Jane
dying in a hospital to foil a crime, but as
the story goes on, readers learned that Peter
was responsible for her death... in the worst
way possible.
You see, the doctors can't figure out why
MJ is dying of radiation poisoning, but Peter
can... since his blood - and ALL his bodily
fluids - are radioactive.
That's right, in the darkest, creepiest, most
unsettling Spider-Man story we know of, Peter
Parker's decision not to use protection killed
his wife.
Still not shocked or convinced this was Peter
Parker's worst murder, no matter what the
future holds?
Look no further than him comparing her illness
to spider eggs hatching inside of her, spreading
cancer throughout her body.
Superman
Man of Steel took plenty of heat for showing
Superman killing his enemy, but ask a die-hard
DC fan, and they'll tell you that "Superman
doesn't kill" isn't exactly true, since more
than a few people and enemies have fallen
at his hands.
But no kill is stranger, or harder to believe,
than the one taking place on an alternate
world the Man of Steel accidentally stumbled
upon.
On this parallel Earth, three Kryptonians
sentenced to the Phantom Zone escaped their
prison to wreak havoc on Earth - and they
did.
By wiping out the atmosphere, the villains,
General Zod among them - managed to kill 5
BILLION souls in a matter of minutes.
In a strange departure from his usual character,
Superman immediately decides that he has no
choice but to act as judge, jury, and executioner.
Sentencing the three to excruciating death,
exposing them to green kryptonite.
It's a scene you wouldn't believe was actually
real, but after burying the three aliens and
returning to his own Earth, the murder, just
or not, haunted Supes for years in the form
of disembodied spirits tormenting his mind.
Captain America
We know what you're thinking: since he started
his comic career as a soldier in World War
2, it's no fair to call Captain America a
killer.
While his wartime kills can mostly be written
off, murdering people turned out to be a hard
habit for Cap to kick, since he was getting
in trouble for killing suspects in even modern
times
But to see Cap's worst streaks of killing,
look no further than Marvel's Cinematic Universe.
Even if we pretend that smashing the edge
of a metal shield made from Earth's toughest
metal into someone's skull isn't enough to
kill them - even without super strength - it
doesn't explain Cap's desire to throw normal
soldiers to their deaths from flying aircraft,
riddle them with machine gun rounds, or just
snap their alien necks (bank fight pre-explosion
in The Avengers).
He may not be any deadlier than his fellow
Avengers, but since he's supposed to be the
poster boy for America's honorable soldiers,
the wake of dead bodies he leaves behind him
is a little unexpected, whether they're bad
guys or not.
Those are just a few of the deadlier sides
of some of our favorite heroes, and we hope
you'll agree that the weirder the stories
or more out of place the bloodlust, the easier
it is to appreciate these characters as the
weird heroic murderers they really are.
Let us know your own examples, and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one!